i know i know you have a phone policy i
understand but this is an emergency
because my friend isn't here
and i'm worried
that he has been abducted no and and no
he ditched you man i saw him drive away
there's no way he dissed me there's no
way that happened he's my okay man
please just use your phone please just
make it quick thank you okay i will make
it quick i will make it very quick
and you don't have my numbers on speed
dial
ah okay what is it
you don't know oh god you don't you know
what i can dial 4-1-1 get jim's number
she left you here on purpose
all right i saw it
he just drove away
actually this is good i am going to take
this opportunity
to go walk about
good good
nope get away
no that's enough
okay
[Applause]
mayor gary gergich died peacefully in
his sleep on his 100th birthday holding
the hand of his beloved wife gail
man gail looks amazing
yeah yeah i know
he will now be given the indiana notary
society's highest honor
the 21 stamp salute
rest in peace
friend they spelled his name wrong on
the tombstone
[Music]
uh
close enough
okay well tell us about your hacker okay
he goes by the handle pandemic and
there's not a network he can't crack
he's a phantom a ghost and only i know
where to find him
welcome to hey hey it's wednesdays where
it's never the weekend be right with you
are you sure about this hacker charles
i'm not getting a strong mr robot vibe
from this place yeah that's because the
only thing pandemic loves more than
hacking computers is hacking into a big
old fried onion
there he is
hey guys welcome to the quarantine help
yourself to some pot stickers best eaten
when high no thanks here are the account
numbers for the bank where the money
showed up i'm in a real hurry you think
you can trace it back to its source
you're questioning my abilities
watch this what's your name terence
vincent jeffords
wait
what's happening you're getting hacked
bro that's what's happening don't do
that i'm in your home computer you are
get out get a lot of songs by natalie
and bruglia oh i bought those back in
the 90s nope download it on thursday
okay now watch the pandemic spread
there's a document here that looks to be
fan fiction for the show madam secretary
oh sarge i didn't know you were a fan of
the madam the show leaves terry one more
i'm just filling in the gaps now get the
hack in i'll have the midweek potato
leek soup and he'll have a there's work
tomorrow so be cool frozen margarita
for you you can call me nightmare but
for check writing purposes it's jennifer
huggins bank's encryption turned out to
be more secure than i thought so i had
to bring in a friend just tell us that
this is impossible we don't have a lot
of time to waste and we've been here
like five hours already huh you don't
think i can do this
is it because i'm a woman no no i didn't
say that i think women are amazing thank
you and now i'm about to hack your world
into pieces old man i'll show you no
just do the thing with the bank that'll
show me whoa looks like someone was a
catalog model in japan
those boots that slicker the no pants
who's the target audience for these
picks sarge i was a starving student
terry needed me in i'm getting worried
we're running out of time it's fine this
place is open 24 5. only closed on
weekends such a strange theme for a
restaurant agreed but that's not what i
meant did you guys find anything yet yes
terry made a sizable purchase at an etsy
store that sells anklets for men
sharon thinks they're sexy come on focus
on the case man oh dip jason ah dead
pill boy oh dear pillboi oh damn donkey
duck
this is remarkable it explains so much
jason i thought you were dead but i was
alive i was in australia i talked to you
on the phone last week yeah but i forgot
oh
i don't know b what if it doesn't work
hey we thought of everything except for
an alibi and an escape route but we'll
figure it out as we go you don't want to
overthink these things kind of freaking
out here go boy i got you this plan is
foolproof and when it's over we can
finally have the lives we deserve
[Music]
i am a safe installer here to install at
a safe so just a point to where the
guacamole money is and i'll install at
the safer in the
how you say a place
yeah hi we're being robbed
gee down to us man this hat's a golf
ball and he's got a terrible mustache we
need to get married now
i do
for el always and forever
i do
so the plan was to pretend to install a
safe with your friend hiding inside it
he pops out steals the buddy from the
restaurant gets back in the safe and you
come in and uninstall it i refuse to
discuss my fifth amendment rights until
i concur with your attorney sure
look we found your buddy's plans we know
he was the
brains and you were just an accomplice
if you get lucky you might get probation
jason going to jail no ma'am
jason's dead
he's suffocating in that safe there are
no air holes plus he did a bunch of
whippets while he was in there which
couldn't have helped
at least he died doing what he loved
a bunch of whippets
now he's never gonna get the life he
truly deserved i i think he got roughly
what he deserved
hey now listen judy you can't make
zanies with these little pink fools
you'll be tripping balls like clarence
was when he crawled into the ice machine
here
take half of one of these
wash it down with a five hour energy and
you'll be golden body high with mild
visuals
thanks bill boy
yo
i gotta take off cause i gotta go do a
robbery
i mean
i'm sick
hello pillboi i'm here on behalf of
jason
you won't be attending the job with
donkey doug today there's been a change
of plans
okay
that's it
you don't need any more information i
mean do you want to tell me not really
cool
you want some pills
your covert mission is to continue to
report to this job until you receive
our signal this is the more important
thing
you cannot commit any more crimes and
you must help these people as much as
you can
the mission depends on roger that man
i can't believe this whole time you guys
were with nasa yes we are secret
astronaut spies
that is indeed what jason told you
take good care of these old fools and
stay out of trouble
i love you bro
i love you bro
it's like i got you bro i got you bro
jake worse
you